we're going on a trip really we're going
in the car can you say hi you give me
high five thank you yeah good boy this
is Rosco
well he loves going to the PA RK I can't
say PA RK because he'll know what PA RK
means and then he'll want to go to the
PA RK so for now we just have to spell
once he learns to spell then we're
doomed
we're doomed I have a pet in my life it
is a cat that we adopted was a rescue
cat her name is Addison one time I
caught Addison trying to get up onto a
shelf that had a lot of delicate glass
things specifically so that she could
accidentally knock them off and then go
what did that how did that happen like
it really had that feeling to it until
in the face okay
check to the butt to the cop walk on
keyboard there you go
coffee on computer and down no when I'm
not around his secret life is
fantasizing and just thinking about a ba
ll not only can we not say PA RK we also
can't say ba ll but I think he just sits
around the house waiting for someone to
return to be able to go to the PA RK
with his ba ll because that's his that's
his deal oh oh please syllable and I
will change it because my brain is the
size of a rat turd okay yeah I get it
hey do you want your ball
I had just flown in from somewhere and I
just needed to sit on the couch and
decompress like from these multiple
plane trips I've just taken and Addison
just came and like wedged herself right
next to me on the couch and she relaxed
and it almost felt like she was trying
to transfer her relaxation over to me
like hey you're home now it's okay that
was a really sweet like I don't know
where a moment of like hey I'm gonna dig
this cat if Addison was a human
what would Addison do for a living my
cat would probably be a blogger and
would probably recap television shows
and would be disappointed in everything
that she watched so many smells I've
never smelled before he would be in law
enforcement or maybe like a firefighter
something a little heroic because I he's
brave he's rugged and brave and he's hey
what do you whine about still whining
here you can't get a reputation as a
lady actor if you do people will start
talking and telling stories about you
yeah no whining jquan no whining but I'm
not going to do any of them now but yeah
there are very specific voices you use
with your pets that are excruciating to
anyone who's not your pet and maybe
they're excruciating to your pet now
that I think about it
[Music]
[Applause]